[Music]
take you to kabul where acting afghan
foreign minister amir khan wataki is
speaking let's listen we were invited to
a conference in geneve
we explained to the envoy of the united
nations
that
the emirates
of
islam in afghanistan
during the meeting they pledged
to extend
relief aid to afghanistan within the
scope of one billion dollar and we are
thankful
to this
we
are sure to the international community
that we are pleased
to hear
about
the
pledge
committed to afghanistan at the same
time
we promise
on our part that all the relief aid
will
reach
the deserved in afghanistan it is our
responsibility to hand out the relief
aid to all the afghanis all across
afghanistan and every corner of the
country
we are capable of handing out the relief
aid to all
that deserved
we are keen on preserving the rights of
the poor
and those in need
meanwhile
it is known that the people of
afghanistan have been
for 40 years
reeling under the brunt of wars during
which
we have faced
all sorts
of troubles
that's why
we hope that the international
community will lend a helping hand to
afghanistan
on
various
domains
this
relief aid
is no doubt considered to be
humanitarian assistance
we also hope that the
international
monetary
fund
to
also
consider providing assistance to
afghanistan especially
many
sectors
are gravely affected from health
health care to
education this
assistance and all forms of pledges
committed to afghanistan
will be channeled
towards the ongoing
development projects
which if
come to a halt
they will have grave repercussion on
afghanistan
and the afghani people
we simply wish to keep all these
projects
running
the government of afghanistan
are doing all what they can
in order to provide job opportunities to
all the afghani people
and those
willing
to leave the country
and seek their future elsewhere
they are free to go however
they have the opportunity to remain in
their homeland
and be of help
to their fellow afghani citizens
at the same time
we are doing all what we can
to provide
a safe and positive atmosphere to all
investors domestic
and foreign
because this is at the end of the day
going to be beneficial
to afghan and afghani people
terms of security we can all see that
order and security are maintained
and this is
a positive sign
and a good assurance
to all investors
domestic
and foreign
we also call on all the afghani
expats who are living abroad
to return home
and
lend a helping hand
to their home country and their fellow
afghani citizens
also those who have fled
in the past
are requested
to go back
to their own property
some claim
that the relief aid will be conditional
on taliban's
dealings with the world community
to this end
we say that at the moment
we are faced with many problems
from health sector to education
and
the flight
of the afghani
talent
so we should not
confuse
political issues
with humanitarian ones
the afghani people is in a dire need
for help
so these
humanitarian forms of aid
should not be linked
to any political
reasons
as we all know that security and order
have been restored in each and every
province within the country there is no
fighting there is no insecurity and
there is no
form
of violation
this is a clear assurance
that our country is safe and it is open
for investment
those are willing to come they are
welcome
at the same time
all people within who are willing to
leave are free to go
provided they are carrying the valid
documents
we have maintained order and security
and we are looking forward to continuing
to live in peace and security and
witness
the positive trans transformation of
our country
here i would like to drive
some examples
at the time of the evacuation of the us
and foreign troops from afghanistan
we provided them with all the
conceivable means
the time
and
the tools
to enable them
safely leave afghanistan
unfortunately
instead of thanking the emirates of
afghanistan
they handled our property in a very
malicious way
they destroyed our property before they
had
before they left
the united states is a civilized country
and they should deal with others
based on mutual respect
we are willing
to deal with all the world countries
based on mutual respect including the
united states
we are not
prepared to get dictated to
or be subjected to any pressure
from any country in the world
we have no problem in dealing with any
country in the world without being
pressured
or dictated to
we cannot
allow
any threats
of
embargo or sanctions be imposed
on our country we are ready and open to
all forms of friendly relations and
friendly talks with all world of the
all the world countries
now we open the floor to questions
you made a statement a while ago
that the interim government
and
as you
demanded the world countries
to recognize your government
as a level have you received any
positive response to this demand so far
as
we speak
we have not seen
any of the world countries openly
recognizing the emirates
of taliban
as a lawful
regime
as i said
we had a several of joint meetings with
the un envoy
and
representatives and officials from
regional countries and other neighboring
countries
they
respectively have expressed
some
concerns and we should listen to them
however we are still
receiving officials
and representatives from arab muslim
and regional countries
each and every country have
its own policy its own foreign policy
if
they are willing
to recognize
the emirates of taliban or the emirates
of islam as a ruler regime
they are
welcome
on our part
we are
in total control of our own home soil
there is
no insecurity or any form of fighting or
infighting within our home soil
it is a clear assurance
a good sign to the whole world
as you mentioned
you have
good relations with many of the world
countries a couple of days ago
the
qatari foreign ministers
provided some suggestions
to your government can you elaborate on
that
as i said earlier
world
countries have approached us with some
concerns others have approached us with
some
suggestions
and as you know
the former government
were functioning
and recognized by the world
community
it is known
that the members of the former
government were not adequate enough
however
on our part
our government which has been announced
a few days ago
is
fully inclusive
it has a clear representations of all
the afghani people from all walks of
life and from each and every corner of
the country
this does not or did not apply
to the former government most of the
former government's officials were
imported from overseas
they
[Music]
landed on
their offices from outside
unlike
our own government
we have
an all-inclusive
government what does this mean
it means
that
we
have full representations of all the
afghani people
from all walks of life
for example
the
government declared
days ago
is a living proof
and also
we will continue to adjust
and as you all know this is
an interim government
we will continue to shovel
amend and modify
until we reach
the final formula
many of the world states
have expressed their concern
about women and women's rights
and by the grace of god almighty we have
our established traditions
cherishing
women and the rights
all the reservations
raised by some countries are not
just
unfair
at the same time they are not acceptable
my
question is
relating to
the
former foreign ministry's officials
what will their future be whether those
within the country or overseas
i can simply assure you
that
all the officials
employed by the former government in the
foreign ministry
and as we said earlier you should
continue to come to office
you should
all report to your own duties
those within afghanistan
or overseas
within the diplomatic missions
consulates and embassies
we
called upon them to continue to function
as usual
the staff
of our diplomatic missions abroad our
embassies and consulates they are
our
representatives they should continue to
function as normal we have no objection
at all
they have all
the liberty
to report to office and this does not
apply only to the foreign ministry
we declared the same
request
to all
former
government officials
they have the liberty
to report to office and to function
as was the habit in the past
as
you all know
we have received relief aid from the
state of qatar
and also from pakistan uzbekistan
and to this end we extend all thanks and
appreciation to these countries
the
relief aid as i mentioned at the
beginning
will be handed out to all
the deserved and
afghani people on all those in need they
will be distributed fairly and squarely
some states pledged
assistance and monetary aid
to afghanistan however many of them have
made their pledges conditional
on your actions
not your words
how do you respond to that
another question
the former government had certain
treaties and promises with
some of the world's countries in terms
of economy entry
as a government as a sitting government
if
all the ongoing agreements
and promises made by the government the
former government
are beneficial to our country and our
people
they
will be honored and we will observe them
provided that they are not in
contradiction with our principles
or the tenets of
our religion
to those countries
who have phrased
certain concerns that we as taliban have
our
domestic problems to them i say
look at the way
we entered cabin
we managed to maintain total control of
the city
without
any form of resistance
this is a clear sign
of how
the movement is accepted
and appealed
to
all the people we have entered the city
without any resistance
and all other provinces
i do not know
what is the basis for these concerns
i
am also surprised
to see those people
demanding human rights and women's
rights
i am really surprised
if they have a different definition of
human rights or women rights
let them provide us with such a
definition
groups to operate in afghanistan
we go back to the
government and the formation of the
recent government
we
are seizing each and every opportunity
lying ahead
and as i said
this is an interim government
we will continue to adjust
and
modify
until we reach a final formation and i
cannot give you a deadline on that
speaking of the future form of
elections and
the form of running the state's affair
i can assure you that each and every
measure will be decided on time i cannot
give you a deadline
on the final formation of the government
or the mechanism through which it will
be formed or elected we are taking one
consideration
in mind which is
the national
interest we assured the international
community that afghani home soil
will not be a launching pad to any
assault or attack on any country
regional
or elsewhere
our position is clear our stand
is firm
if we make a promise
we fulfill such a promise we keep our
promises it is part of the tenets of our
religion
similarly we request the world countries
not to interfere in our own domestic
affairs
the first question
is about
uh the members of the interim government
most of the current
members of the government are
blacklisted
by some
world states
another question we heard reports that
there are some problems
with other factions within afghanistan
against your movement
at the time we were negotiating
a peace deal with the united states
we had agreed with them
as we signed the agreement we agreed
with them
on certain
issues
including
that
the
personalities blacklisted
should be removed from such a blacklist
this was part of the negotiations
and agreement signed with the united
states in the past
there are we just cut away uh from press
conference that we were hearing from the
acting afghan foreign minister amir khan
multaki who was speaking there just to
recap for you what we heard there he
explained that the uh he spoke to the un
envoy uh and told him that the pledge of
a billion dollars that has just been
made by international donors as welcomed
and promised that the taliban will
ensure that it reaches those who need it
he also called on all afghani expats to
return home and said uh that the interim
government is doing all it can to
provide job opportunities to the afghan
people i also gave assurances to the
international community that the taliban
says it will uphold human rights
he said that if they the international
community have a different definition we
do have human rights or women's rights
let them provide us with that definition
and we will bring you the very latest on
that press conference as it comes to
hand